bon écoute et je crois je vais être
obligé de vous faire une interview psy
[Musique]
c'est formidable c'est dire yako et caf
a expliqué on ne bouge pas pendant le
jingle ça c'est formidable c'est énorme
dites-moi interruption donc on va faire
un petit tour de votre psychisme
d'accord est ce que vous êtes parano ça
m'arrive donc l occasion mais j'ai droit
à des jo cas ou pas abattant des si vous
avez vous prenez des jokers c'est
anconina et géra qui répondent à votre
place non non je suis parano quand je
suis pas très bien dans ma peau et quand
préféré répondre vous finalement être
fumé trop de cigarettes
c'est dégueulasse il ya des gars arrêtez
vous avez arrêté à moitié moitié et
adorable est ce que vous êtes schizo pas
du tout enfin ça peut non non ça va de
ce côté là ça va est ce que vous êtes
maso non enfin envers moi même ça peut
m'arriver aussi vous fait du mal je peux
me faire du mal à moi même way est ce
que vous aimez quand vous fasse du mal
non non non ne vous plaît pas ça est ce
que vous êtes ado ado de me faire mal
non je n'ai pas peur non ça me plait pas
bien mais jusque là ça va
est ce que vous êtes sado maso ça rend
la prod ou ce c'est bien connu
non moi je préfère qu'elles soient
douces en douceur donc j'ai pas du temps
dans la violence est ce que vous êtes
géronto je sais pas ce que c'est gérante
hausse et des filles qui aiment bien les
vieux vieux oui je me doutais bien que
vieux je sais pas ce que c'est
exactement vieux non plus vieux comme
moi quoi mais moi je ne trouve pas vieux
par exercer non mes vieux genre vieux à
partir de 60 70 non je suis pas
gérontologie d'accord mais jusqu'à quel
âge vous êtes jusqu'à quel âge un
gérontologue à partir de quel âge je ne
sais pas 50
ça va encore est ce que vous êtes porno
je pas vous aimez regarder des cas c'est
des machins dans ce sens après du tout
pas du tout non je suis pas du tout
porno à moi j'aime pas ça ah non je peux
être porno mais pas par borg avait
jamais de films pornos par exemple
jamais non franchement ça me vous fait
rien trouve pas que c'est non l'été
c'est normal comme fille a assez vous ne
regardez jamais non plus vous riche à
moi je regarde pas parce que le cas vous
aussi à presque jamais il faut attendre
un quart d'heure si on s'en sert pas
pendant huit jours c'est vrai foot
histoire c'est qu'il faut attendre un
quart d'heure
non
et vous jamais préfère participer moi à
oui oui que le voir à la télé tu vois
c'est marrant mais moi je préfère
participer
ouais l'affairé tracts est ce que vous
êtes vdo celle inverse de géronto je dis
ça pour nos amis téléspectateurs qui
n'ont pas l'habitude de tous ses maux et
doan ont pedu non plus vous êtes au jeu
vous êtes travelo vous a déjà tenté la
disant vous êtes vachement sérieuses
comme fille moi c'est le truc noir
mollahs que je suis la rdc les
déviations les plus communes des
français c'est vrai c'est le top 15 des
déviations des français ça là je préfère
normal que sérieuse bon excuse et de
disco ah ouais
[Musique]
je vous demande de vous arrêter je vous
demande de vous arrêter à nîmes
dans tous les cas merci j'ai bien
aimable pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de nos latitudes abonnez vous il mettait
un peu de bleu